Hey there, everybody. If you're listening on our podcast or the internet, there are words in this episode that we have un-beeped. If you prefer a beeped version of the show, you could find that at our website, thisamericanlife.org. There are 9-1-1 calls where people are basically calling the cops on the cops. Lisa Mahon did that in September. She was on her way to the county hospital in Chicago. Her mom was dying and the hospital called, saying that she'd stopped breathing and had just been put on a ventilator. So Lisa had her two kids in the back and her friend Jamal was up front, and she was just about to pull into the expressway near Hammond, Indiana, near where she lives, when a police officer pulled her over for not wearing a seat belt.
大家好。如果你是在我们的播客或互联网上收听，本期节目中有一些原本被“哔”掉的词，我们已经恢复了。如果你更喜欢收听消音版，可以在我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org 上找到。有一些拨打 911 的电话，人们基本上是在向警察举报警察。丽莎·马洪在九月就这么做了。当时她正在去芝加哥县医院的路上。她母亲病危，医院打来电话，说她母亲呼吸停止，刚刚用上了呼吸机。丽莎带着两个孩子在后座，朋友贾马尔坐在前座。她正准备开进印第安纳州哈蒙德市附近的高速公路，离她家不远，这时一名警察因为她没系安全带把她拦了下来。
Now, the strange part about all of this is when he asked me for my license and insurance, usually, the police officer gets back in the car and runs the license plates, runs the license. He didn't do any of that. He put the information in his pocket and never took it out. What officer puts it in a pocket and not go to the police car?
最奇怪的部分在于，当他向我要驾照和保险时，通常情况下，警察会回到警车里去查车牌和驾照。他什么都没做，只是把信息放进口袋里，再也没拿出来过。哪个警察会把信息揣进兜里而不回警车的？
And what's his manner like when he asked you for the license?
他向你要驾照时是什么态度？
Oh my god. Well, first of all, he's moving from side to side. His body is not still. His eyes wasn't blinking. He was really acting kind of hyper. He wasn't acting professional. He wasn't acting like a police officer at all.
天哪。首先，他在左右摇晃。他的身体站不稳。他的眼睛没眨过。他表现得非常亢奋，一点也不专业，完全不像个警察。
Lisa had been in law enforcement herself. She'd been a corrections officer. Her dad taught criminal justice. She's got no problem with cops at all. But this one was acting so weird, she says, she kept her window up.
丽莎本人也从事过执法工作。她曾是一名管教人员。她父亲教犯罪学。她对警察一点偏见都没有。但她说，这个警察表现得太怪了，她一直把车窗关着。
The officer, Lieutenant Patrick Fucari, didn't return our calls. According to Lisa and to a statement issued by the Hammond police, Lieutenant Fucari next asked for Jamal's ID. Jamal was sitting in the passenger seat and, Lisa says, wearing a seat belt, so it's not clear why this was necessary. Jamal didn't have his ID. According to the police statement, Jamal moved his hand below where the officer could see and the officer started fearing for his own safety. A second officer arrived. The interaction got weird enough that Lisa turned to her 14-year-old in the backseat and asked him to do what people do these days in this situation.
这名警官，帕特里克·福卡里中尉，没有回复我们的电话。据丽莎和哈蒙德警方发表的声明，福卡里中尉接下来要求查看贾马尔的身份证。贾马尔当时坐在副驾驶座上，丽莎说他系着安全带，所以不清楚为什么非要看他的证件。贾马尔没带身份证。据警方声明，贾马尔的手移到了警官视线之外，导致警官开始担心自身安全。第二名警察赶到了。互动变得非常奇怪，丽莎转身对后座 14 岁的孩子说，让他做现在人们在这种情况下会做的事。
Jojo, get your phone out and videotape this.
乔乔，拿出你的手机，把这个录下来。
I'm already doing it.
我已经在录了。
The officers asked Jamal to get out of the car. Jamal didn't want to get out, and through the window, he asked for what he called a white shirt, a supervisor.
警察让贾马尔下车。贾马尔不想下车，透过车窗，他要求见他所说的“白衬衫”，也就是主管。
Y'all got a white shirt?
你们有白衬衫（主管）吗？
Look at my shoulder, dumb ass. I got the bars.
看看我的肩膀，笨蛋。我有警衔。
"I got the bars." He is a supervisor. From the police perspective, Jamal is not complying. Jamal starts looking for a ticket that he'd gotten that could prove who he is. He reaches into his book bag.
“我有警衔。”他是个主管。从警方的角度来看，贾马尔不配合。贾马尔开始寻找他之前拿到的一张罚单，可以证明他的身份。他伸手去拿书包。
As soon as he went inside the bag, that's when the two officers pulled the gun out.
他刚一进包里，两名警察就拔出了枪。
I got my kids in the car. You're drawing your weapon.
我的孩子还在车里。你们竟然拔出了武器。
It continues like this. Lisa starts to feel like these cops are not acting the way cops should. Let's get some adults here. There must be somebody above these people, and she calls 9-1-1.
情况就这样持续着。丽莎开始觉得这些警察的行为不像是警察该有的样子。得找个成年人来。这些人上面肯定还有人，于是她拨打了 911。
Hammond 9-1-1.
哈蒙德 911。
The police just pulled a gun on me. I'm sitting in my car. And then they're asking me to open the door. I am scared.
警察刚对我拔了枪。我正坐在车里。现在他们叫我打开车门。我很害怕。
"The officer pulled a gun on me, I'm sitting in my car, they asked me to open the door, I'm scared," she says.
“警察对我拔了枪，我正坐在车里，他们叫我打开车门，我很害怕，”她说。
Calm down. Pulling out a gun-- are you opening-- are you getting-- are you following the officer's orders?
冷静点。拔出枪——你在打开——你在——你在执行警察的命令吗？
Now they're asking me to open the door. I'm scared to open the door.
他们现在叫我打开车门。我害怕打开车门。
Why are you scared to open the door?
你为什么害怕打开车门？
Because he pulled a gun out.
因为他拔出了枪。
OK. If he's pulling a gun out, maybe because he is in fear of his life as well.
好吧。如果他拔出枪，可能是因为他也在担心自己的生命安全。
No. We don't have anything.
不。我们什么都没有。
Ma'am, ma'am, ma'am.
女士，女士，女士。
Yes, yes.
是的，是的。
He cannot see in your vehicle. You--
他看不见你的车内。你——
She said the officer can't see in the vehicle. I said, what do you mean he can't see in the window? I said it's broad daylight.
她说警官看不见车内。我说，你什么意思，他看不见窗户里？我说现在可是光天化日之下。
All you need to do is follow the officer's orders.
你只需要听从警官的命令就行了。
I'm scared to open the door.
我害怕打开车门。
Do you think the dispatcher understood why you were afraid?
你觉得接线员理解你为什么害怕吗？
She didn't care. She didn't care. She never was helpful.
她根本不在乎。她根本不在乎。她从头到尾都没帮上忙。
Now I'm scared for my life.
现在我害怕得要命。
Why are you scared for your life? It's a police officer pulling you over for--
你为什么害怕你的生命安全？这只是警察因为——把你拦下来而已。
Because he pulled a gun on us.
因为他拔枪对着我们。
Are you going to-- are you going to stop screaming and listen?
你要——你要停止尖叫并听我说吗？
Were you surprised at the tone she took with you?
你对她跟你说话的态度感到惊讶吗？
Oh, yes. It was unbelievable. I don't have no help. No one's going to help.
哦，是的。简直不可思议。我得不到任何帮助。没人会帮我。
OK. Number one, if you're getting pulled over by an officer for not wearing your seat belt, if you cooperate, there would be no problem. You would already be at the hospital.
好吧。第一，如果你是因为没系安全带被拦下，如果你配合的话，根本就不会有问题。你早就到医院了。
The Hammond police statement on this incident runs two pages but does not mention Officer Fucari drawing his gun. It does say that the officer was afraid that the passengers had a gun, though it doesn't say why this mom and her friend and two kids would make him think that.
哈蒙德警方关于此事件的声明有两页长，但没提福卡里警官拔枪的事。声明确实提到警官担心乘客有枪，尽管没说为什么这名母亲、她的朋友和两个孩子会让他产生这种想法。
Can I ask you, do you think if it had been me who had been pulled over, do you think he would have treated me that way?
能问一下吗，你觉得如果换做是我被拦下，他会那样对待我吗？
Oh, absolutely not.
哦，绝对不会。
Because I'm white?
因为我是白人？
Right.
对。
Then you need to just get out of the car. They're not going to hurt you if you listen.
那你就该下车。如果你听话，他们不会伤害你的。
What are you saying somebody's not going to hurt you? People are getting shot by the police.
你说什么“不会伤害你”？人们正被警察枪杀呢。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
（交叉发言）
The next thing that happens you may have seen on the news from her son's video.
接下来发生的事情，你可能已经在她儿子拍的视频新闻里看到了。
No. Don't mess my-- now they're about to mess my-- no!
不。别弄坏我的——现在他们要弄坏我的——不！
[BREAKING GLASS]
（玻璃破碎声）
[SCREAMING]
（尖叫声）
Oh [BLEEP].
哦，该死。
[YELLING]
（大喊声）
The police bust through Jamal's window, taser him, open the door, and pull him out. He was arrested for failure to aid an officer and resisting law enforcement.
警察砸碎了贾马尔的车窗，对他使用电击枪，打开车门，将他拖了出来。他因未能配合警察和拒捕而被捕。
[CRYING]
（哭泣声）
Lisa says 9-1-1 hung up on her when they heard the window smash. In the end of all this, the car damaged, her kid's crying, she was handed a ticket for not wearing a seat belt.
丽莎说，当 911 接线员听到砸窗声时，直接挂断了她的电话。事后，车子受损，孩子在哭，而她拿到了一张不系安全带的罚单。
[CRYING]
（哭泣声）
People in our country do not agree on what to make of a story like this. Lots of people hear the story or see the video and they side with the dispatcher, right? If you're stopped by the police, just do what the officer says. It'll be fine. This is what lots of people said after Eric Garner died while being arrested in July in New York. People said it after Michael Brown was shot in Ferguson in August. Then there are lots of people like Lisa who say if you're black, it might not be fine.
我们国家的人对这类事情的看法并不统一。很多人听了故事或看了视频，都会站在接线员那一边，对吧？如果你被警察拦下，只要照做就行了。一切都会好的。七月埃里克·加纳在纽约被捕时身亡后，很多人就是这么说的。八月迈克尔·布朗在弗格森被枪杀后，人们也这么说。但也有很多人像丽莎一样说，如果你是黑人，情况可能就不一样了。
I was petrified. I just thought it was over.
我当时吓坏了。我以为一切都完了。
Our country is divided on this-- people who think the police are on their side, people who don't, but it's complicated. For instance, if you're starting to think you know which side of the divide Lisa's on, especially after that experience, well--
我们国家对此存在分歧——有人认为警察站在他们那边，有人不这么认为，但情况很复杂。例如，如果你开始以为你知道丽莎属于哪一边，尤其是在经历了那次遭遇之后，那么——
Oh, I still trust the police. So I don't have anything against the police officers. I think they deserve all the respect in the world. The other day, there was a police officer on the side of the road with his blinkers on. I pulled over and asked him if he was OK.
哦，我仍然信任警察。所以我对警察没有任何意见。我觉得他们值得世上所有的尊重。前几天，路边有个警察开着闪光灯，我停下车问他是否还好。
It was just this one officer, she says. He was the problem. She's now suing the city of Hammond over the incident and has learned that this officer was named in three other lawsuits for using excessive force. In all three, the city settled. For so long now, there's been this conversation or debate-- I don't know what you want to call this-- about policing and race and people being targeted, and whenever it comes up, it seems to split very quickly into a kind of my side versus your side sort of thing.
她说，只是那一个警察的问题。她现在正因这起事件起诉哈蒙德市，并得知那名警官曾因过度使用武力被卷入另外三起诉讼。在三起案件中，市政府都达成了和解。很长一段时间以来，一直存在着关于警务、种族和针对性执法的讨论或辩论——我不知道该叫它什么——每当提到这些，似乎很快就会演变成“我这一边”对立“你那一边”的情况。
In these last few months, we've been talking about this stuff amongst ourselves here on the radio show staff and researching and reporting in different parts of the country, and we have found some things that surprised us about policing and how complicated and difficult it is, and about how hard it is to sort out the part that race and racism play in all kinds of incidents, and we found ways that racism seems undeniable. Anyway, we discovered things that made us see some of this differently and we want to share that with you this week and next. We have found so much of this, we actually couldn't fit it into one episode. So from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
过去几个月里，我们在电台节目组内部一直在讨论这些问题，并在全国各地进行研究和报道。我们发现了一些关于警务、关于其复杂性和困难程度，以及关于理清种族和种族主义在各类事件中所起作用的难度等方面令人惊讶的事实，我们还发现了种族主义似乎不可否认的证据。无论如何，我们发现的一些事情让我们用不同的眼光看待这些问题，我们想在本周和下周与你们分享。我们发现的内容太多了，一集节目根本装不下。我是艾拉·格拉斯，这是来自芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》。请继续收听。
So today, what we're going to do is we're going to focus on just one police department, a police department with a troubled history, and we're going to tell the story of the chief who is trying to change that and why it is so hard to change certain things. Brian Reed tells the story.
所以今天，我们要专注于一个警局，一个有着复杂历史的警局，我们要讲述一位试图改变现状的警察局长的故事，以及为什么某些事情改变起来如此困难。布莱恩·里德讲述了这个故事。
When Chief Ed Flynn took over the Milwaukee police department in 2008, he was coming into one of the most segregated cities in America, a city that sends enormous numbers of black men to prison. Wisconsin sends the highest percentage of black men to prison of any state in the country, and in Milwaukee, that means more than half of black men in their 30s and early 40s have been to prison. And just to give you a sense of how bad relations got between black residents and police, in 2004, the city saw a brutal incident that some people call Milwaukee's Rodney King case, the beating of Frank Jude.
当埃德·弗林局长于 2008 年接管密尔沃基警察局时，他进入的是美国种族隔离最严重的城市之一，一座向监狱输送大量黑人的城市。威斯康星州在全国输送黑人男性入狱的比例最高，在密尔沃基，这意味着 30 多岁到 40 多岁出头的黑人男性中，有一半以上曾入狱。为了让你了解黑人居民与警察之间的关系有多糟糕，2004 年，该市发生了一起残暴事件，有些人称之为“密尔沃基的罗德尼·金案”，即弗兰克·朱德遭殴打事件。
They're beating him up.
他们在殴打他。
OK. [INAUDIBLE].
好。（听不清）。
Jude was an exotic dancer. He did bachelorette parties. And one night after work, he ended up at a party full of off duty police officers. A group of about a dozen officers, all of whom were white and many of whom were drunk, surrounded Jude, who was black, and started beating him. They claimed he'd stolen one of their badges. Just like in the incident you heard about at the beginning of the show, one of the women who'd brought Frank Jude to the party decided to call 9-1-1 on the cops as they handcuffed Jude, cut his clothes off, and essentially tortured him-- kicked him repeatedly, bent his fingers back, shoved a pen in his ears, causing them to bleed. Even when the dispatcher sent on duty officers to the scene, one of them joined in the beating, stomping on Frank Jude's head while the other officers stood by.
朱德曾是一名脱衣舞男。他接单参加单身派对。一天下班后，他误打误撞进入了一个全是下班警察的派对。大约十几名警察，全是白人，而且很多人喝醉了，他们围住黑人朱德，开始殴打他。他们声称他偷了他们其中一人的警徽。就像你在节目开头听到的那个事件一样，带弗兰克·朱德去那个派对的女性之一，决定在警察给朱德戴上手铐、剪掉他的衣服并实际上对他进行拷打时拨打 911——他们反复踢他，掰断他的手指，把笔塞进他的耳朵里，导致他耳部流血。即使当接线员派当班警察赶到现场时，其中一人也加入了殴打，踩在弗兰克·朱德的头上，而其他警察则在旁边袖手旁观。
They're kicking him, too.
他们也在踢他。
You're saying that the two officers that just arrived in the squad got out and started beating your friend also?
你是说那两名刚赶到的警察下了警车，也开始殴打你的朋友？
Yeah. They're holding him down. They're beating-- [INAUDIBLE].
是的。他们按住他。他们在打——（听不清）。
Eventually, seven officers were fired, three were sentenced to over 15 years in prison, but before that, officers closed ranks. No one talked. No one knew anything. It showed the city how cops would turn the other way and protect their own even if they saw something truly terrible. The case hung over Milwaukee for years.
最终，七名警察被解雇，三人被判处 15 年以上监禁，但在那之前，警察们结成联盟。没人开口。没人知道任何事。这向全城展示了警察如何即使看到真正可怕的事情，也会选择转过头去保护同僚。这个案件多年来一直笼罩在密尔沃基上空。
So this was the climate Ed Flynn was walking into when he became chief. Flynn had been in law enforcement for 35 years. He'd led several small city departments-- Chelsea and Springfield in Massachusetts, and Arlington, Virginia. He'd served as Secretary of Public Safety for the whole state of Massachusetts. But when the job opened up in Milwaukee, it had a special appeal.
这就是埃德·弗林担任局长时面临的环境。弗林已经在执法部门工作了 35 年。他曾领导过几个小城市的部门——马萨诸塞州的切尔西和斯普林菲尔德，以及弗吉尼亚州的阿灵顿。他曾担任整个马萨诸塞州的公共安全秘书。但当密尔沃基出现空缺时，它有一种特殊的吸引力。
One of the attractive things for Milwaukee for me was that it had a very significant crime problem, highly concentrated in communities that had an historical antipathy for their police department.
对密尔沃基来说，吸引我的地方在于它有一个非常严重的犯罪问题，高度集中在那些历史上对警察局怀有反感的社区。
That's what was attractive to you, crime and antipathy for the police?
这就是吸引你的地方，犯罪和对警察的反感？
I mean, absolutely. I mean, to me, Milwaukee represented the crux of the challenge of American policing in the 21st century.
我的意思是，当然。对我来说，密尔沃基代表了 21 世纪美国警务核心挑战。
And as Chief Flynn sees it, that challenge is--
而正如弗林局长所见，那个挑战是——
Those neighborhoods that need us the most and demand our services, when they get us, get mad at us. How do we bridge that?
那些最需要我们并要求我们提供服务的社区，当他们真的得到我们服务时，却对我们感到愤怒。我们如何弥合这一点？
Flynn says he's confronted this his whole career, all the way back to when he started out as a beat cop in the '70s in Jersey City.
弗林说他整个职业生涯都面临这个问题，一直追溯到 70 年代他在泽西市当巡警的时候。
I would go to street corners and there'd be, like, six black kids on a corner in an all black neighborhood. I would always end up with a call for service saying complaints about kids hanging on a corner. Go back to that corner. OK, kids you've got to move. You're just harassing us because we're black. OK, do you see anybody else in this neighborhood? Why do you think I'm picking on you? I said, somebody called. Well, who are they? We want to know. We have a right to stand here. Point is folks that were calling us up looked just like the people that were hanging on the corner.
我会去街角，那里会有六个黑人小孩站在全黑人社区的街角。我总是会接到服务电话，投诉孩子们站在街角。我会回到那个街角。好吧，孩子们，你们得走。你们只是因为我们是黑人而骚扰我们。好吧，你们在这个社区里看到其他人了吗？为什么你们认为我在找你们麻烦？我说，有人打了电话。好吧，他们是谁？我们想知道。我们有权站在这里。重点是那些打电话给我们的人，看起来和站在街角的人一模一样。
Flynn still sees this today in Milwaukee. Most of the city's crime victims are African American and they're the group that has the most animosity towards the police. That's not just in Milwaukee, obviously, but all around the country. So here's a problem people have been debating heatedly, especially since Michael Brown was killed in Ferguson, and here's a guy who's been trying to fix the problem, to mend the relationship between black residents and the police in his city for the last seven years. He's idealistic. He's smart. He can sound very professorial, especially when he talks about the history of poverty and crime and policing. He goes in front of residents and says things like this.
弗林今天在密尔沃基仍然看到了这一点。该市大多数犯罪受害者是非裔美国人，他们是对警察敌意最大的群体。这显然不仅在密尔沃基，在全国各地都是如此。所以这里有一个人们一直在激烈争论的问题，尤其是在迈克尔·布朗在弗格森被杀之后，而这里有一个人一直在试图解决这个问题，试图在过去七年里修补他城市中黑人居民与警察之间的关系。他理想主义，他聪明。他听起来非常有教授范，尤其是当他谈到贫困、犯罪和警务的历史时。他站在居民面前，说出这样的话。
We in this police department and in the police profession know we have inherited a social history of which we can't always be proud. The police have often been in the middle of great conflict and not infrequently been agents of social control to preserve a status quo.
我们这个警察部门和警察行业内部知道，我们继承了一段我们并不总能引以为豪的社会历史。警察经常处于巨大冲突的中心，并经常作为维护现状的社会控制代理人。
By the way, he's not reading here. This is just how he talks.
顺便说一句，他不是在读稿子。这就是他说话的方式。
And certainly in Milwaukee in the last 40 years, you've have your own rich history, sometimes between the police and the community. So we've been working real hard in improving our relationship with neighborhoods so we had achieved some level of legitimacy.
当然，在过去的 40 年里，密尔沃基也有自己丰富的历史，有时是在警察和社区之间。所以我们一直在非常努力地改善与社区的关系，以达到某种程度的合法性。
Flynn became police chief in 2008. So what's he done? How's it going? He didn't enact one single big reform. It was lots of smaller, sometimes boring stuff. He created a code of conduct, redrew the borders of police districts, shifted hundreds of officers from the citywide detective unit onto the streets, a move that wasn't popular in the department. He did a big push to work with dozens of community groups. He started this program with researchers at the University of Wisconsin Milwaukee to go into schools and teach kids in high crime areas why police are stopping people more often in their neighborhoods, how they should behave during stops, and how officers should behave.
弗林于 2008 年成为警察局长。那么他做了什么？进展如何？他没有颁布任何一项重大的改革。全是很多琐碎、有时很枯燥的事情。他制定了行为准则，重划了警察辖区的边界，将数百名警察从全市侦探组调到了街头，这一举措在部门内并不受欢迎。他大力推动与数十个社区团体合作。他与威斯康星大学密尔沃基分校的研究人员发起了这个项目，走进学校，向高犯罪区的孩子们传授为什么警察在他们的社区拦下人的次数更多，他们应该如何在拦截中表现，以及警官应该如何表现。
So how would you, as a kid, feel walking in this area, knowing what you know now, and the police stop you?
那么作为一个孩子，知道你现在所知道的一切，如果警察拦下你，你会怎么想？
I would be upset.
我会很难过。
OK.
好吧。
But you should be appreciative and happy that they're doing something.
但你应该感激并高兴他们在做些什么。
As I spent time with members of the department, it was hard to pinpoint exactly what effect these changes have had, but I did get the sense that something had changed, even if it was sometimes intangible. For instance, I kept hearing certain words again and again. The most popular noun I heard, "community." The most popular verb?
当我花时间与部门成员在一起时，很难准确指出这些变化产生了什么影响，但我确实感到有些事情变了，即使它有时是无形的。例如，我一直在反复听到某些词。我听到的最流行的名词是“社区”。最流行的动词？
We're here to engage and have a conversation.
我们在这里是为了接触并进行对话。
The officers should be marketing all the opportunities to engage with us.
警察应该推销所有与我们接触的机会。
It has helped us to become more engaged in the community.
它帮助我们更深入地融入社区。
Our community engagement and the activities that we've been doing.
我们的社区参与以及我们一直在做的活动。
Building police legitimacy takes place when you directly engage.
建立警察合法性发生在你直接参与的时候。
Of course, police departments all over the country use these exact buzzwords-- say they're engaging more and doing community policing-- but it's hard to know what this actually means.
当然，全国各地的警察部门都使用这些完全一样的流行词——说他们正在更多地参与并进行社区警务——但很难知道这实际上意味着什么。
I'm sorry I threw "engagement" out there. I'm trying to get engaged.
抱歉，我抛出了“参与”这个词。我正试图接触。
No, it's all good. It's a term that you guys use, but I think that doesn't mean a lot to the outside world.
不，挺好的。这是你们这些人用的一个术语，但我认为这对外界来说意义不大。
Right, right.
对，对。
I'm on an evening shift with Sergeant Theresa Janick. She's been on the force seven years. She's worked juvenile crimes, auto thefts. She worked undercover. Now she's a supervisor and she says it's an entirely new police department.
我正和特蕾莎·贾尼克警官上夜班。她在警队工作了七年。她处理过青少年犯罪、汽车盗窃。她做过卧底。现在她是一名主管，她说这是一个全新的警察部门。
10-4, thank you. Go ahead and respond to 3291 to the shots fired.
收到，谢谢。继续响应 3291 的枪击报案。
3217. I can respond to that as well. We could use just one more squad.
3217。我也能响应那个。我们需要再多一个小组。
Sergeant Janick works in district three, a largely black area with one of the highest crime rates in the city. At around six o'clock, she heads to a block where shots have been reported.
贾尼克警官在第三区工作，这是一个主要是黑人的地区，犯罪率是城市中最高的之一。大约六点钟，她前往报案有枪声的街区。
So now we're in the area. We're going to try and see what we can stir up.
所以我们现在在区域内。我们要看看能查出什么。
Do you see anything going on out here, bud?
伙计，你看到外面有什么情况吗？
Nothing out here.
外面什么也没有。
Janick talks through her window to a guy on the sidewalk. He says he's been out there like five minutes.
贾尼克透过车窗与人行道上的一个人交谈。他说他在外面待了大约五分钟。
You didn't hear anything?
你什么都没听到吗？
Not five minutes ago.
不是五分钟前。
About five minutes ago you heard something?
大约五分钟前你听到了什么？
No, no.
不，不。
It's worth noting that the gunshot Janick is responding to, she didn't learn about it from a 9-1-1 call. She learned about it from something called Shot Spotter. It's new technology that Chief Flynn and several other chiefs around the country have put in place that uses sensors around the city to detect when gunshots go off and tells the cops what block they happened on. What that means, though, is that even though Janick talks to several people who say, yeah, I heard a shot, not one of them called 9-1-1. No one in the neighborhood did. Sergeant Janick says this is common. When they installed Shot Spotter, the department found out that only 17% of all the shots fired were resulting in residents calling the police.
值得注意的是，贾尼克响应的枪声，她并不是从 911 电话中得知的。她是从名为“枪声定位系统”（Shot Spotter）的技术中得知的。这是弗林局长和全国其他几位局长实施的一项新技术，利用城市周围的传感器检测枪声何时响起，并告诉警察发生在哪个街区。然而，这意味着，即使贾尼克与几名说“是的，我听到了枪声”的人交谈，他们中没有一个人拨打 911。社区里没有人这样做。贾尼克警官说这是常态。当他们安装“枪声定位系统”时，部门发现所有枪击事件中只有 17% 是由居民拨打警察电话造成的。
You heard it? Where do you think you heard it from?
你听到了？你觉得你是从哪里听到的？
From back here.
从后面这里。
From back here somewhere in this lot?
从这个地段后面的某个地方？
Mm-hm.
嗯。
All right. We'll let you guys get out of here, OK?
好吧。我们让你们离开这儿，好吗？
OK.
好。
The Milwaukee police department's standard operating procedures Chief Flynn put into place include this line. "Police members can be expected to make numerous contacts with the public on a daily basis. These contacts form the basis for the relationship between the department and the community." I rode on three shifts and watched a bunch of different officers, and one thing that struck me was how a single 9-1-1 call or just a single shot fired on Shot Spotter could quickly lead an officer to talking to a dozen people or more as they try to figure out what happened.
弗林局长实施的密尔沃基警察局标准作业程序中包括这一行。“警察成员每天都预计会与公众进行多次接触。这些接触构成了部门与社区之间关系的基础。”我搭乘了三个班次，观察了一堆不同的警察，令我震惊的一件事是，仅仅一个 911 电话或“枪声定位系统”上的一声枪响，就能迅速导致警官与十几个人甚至更多人交谈，因为他们试图弄清楚发生了什么。
With this shot fired, for instance, when I was out with Sergeant Janick, there was no conclusion. They didn't find a shooter or a bullet or a casing, but still, it was an excuse for Sergeant Janick to interact with at least seven people, and it was easy for those conversations to move beyond the gunshot she was there to look into, like with this woman who was coming out of her garage.
比如这次枪声，当我和贾尼克警官在一起时，没有结论。他们没有找到枪手、子弹或弹壳，但尽管如此，这还是贾尼克警官与至少七个人交流的借口，而且这些谈话很容易超出她前来查看的枪声范围，就像和这位刚从车库出来的女士一样。
Ma'am, did you hear anything out here?
女士，你在这里听到什么了吗？
You said did I hear anything?
你是说我听到了什么？
Yeah.
是的。
No, I didn't.
不，我没有。
Nothing? How long have you been here?
没有？你在这里待了多久了？
I live in this building, so I was downstairs in the garage for, like, 10 minutes.
我住在这栋楼里，所以我下楼在车库待了大约 10 分钟。
Did you see anything crazy on the block lately?
最近街区有什么疯狂的事发生吗？
It's always crazy stuff going on around here.
这里总是发生疯狂的事情。
Do you call?
你打过电话吗？
Huh?
哈？
Do you call?
你打过电话吗？
Uh-uh. It's just people outside, drunk people, like. I just mind my business. As long as I don't see anything like someone fighting or something like that, I will say something, but other than that, no.
呃呃。外面就是些人，喝醉的人之类的。我只是管好自己的事。只要我没看到有人打架之类的，我就会说出来，但除此之外，没有。
OK. Can you do me a favor and call that stuff in when you see it so that we can help you out with some of the problems that are going on over here?
好吧。你能帮我个忙吗？当你看到那种事的时候打个电话报案，这样我们可以帮你解决这里正在发生的一些问题？
OK. No problem. I didn't know that you guys wanted us to call that stuff in, but I will if I see anything.
好的。没问题。我不知道你们希望我们报那种事，但如果我看到什么，我会打的。
Yeah. If there's a problem, we want to know about it.
是的。如果有什么问题，我们想知道。
OK.
好的。
All right?
好吧？
All right.
好吧。
Thank you.
谢谢。
You're welcome.
不客气。
On one of her trips around the block, Sergeant Janick asks a man staggering outside a liquor store if everything's OK. He tells Janick that he's been robbed at gunpoint two times recently on that corner. Did you contact the police, Janick asks him. Nope, he says. Would you like to report it now? Yes. She gets two officers to come take the report for him.
在她绕街区巡逻的其中一趟行程中，贾尼克警官问一个在酒铺外摇摇晃晃的男人是否还好。他告诉贾尼克，他最近在那个街角两次被持枪抢劫。贾尼克问他，你联系过警察吗？他说没有。你现在想报案吗？是的。她让两名警官来为他做笔录。
So that was engagement. We just saw engagement.
所以那就是参与。我们刚刚看到了参与。
I hate-- now that you say that we say it all the time--
我讨厌——既然你说了我们总是这么说——
No, it's fine, because I think you just--
不，没关系，因为我觉得你刚刚——
Now I'm noticing it.
现在我注意到了。
No, no, no. That, actually, I think I just finally saw what engagement was.
不，不，不。那个，实际上，我觉得我终于看到了什么是参与。
Yeah.
是的。
I know. Listening to residents and actually trying to help them. It didn't strike me as revolutionary, either. But Assistant Chief James Harpole, who's been with the Milwaukee police department for nearly 30 years, told my producer Ben Calhoun and me about this one time before Chief Flynn but not that long ago, when he went with an officer to a neighborhood meeting.
我知道。听取居民意见并真正试图帮助他们。这对我来说也不觉得是革命性的。但担任密尔沃基警察局近 30 年的副局长詹姆斯·哈波尔告诉我，在我制片人本·卡尔霍恩和我之前，在弗林局长之前，甚至没多久前，当他和一个警察去参加社区会议时。
A number of concerns were brought to our attention, and he was writing them all in his book, and we left the meeting. And I said, OK, so what's the next step? He said, well, nothing. He said, I just keep these in my book, and if it ever comes up again, I can say how we were aware of it. I'm like, OK, that's not going to cut it for me. I said, these people expect that something's going to happen here. We can't just write it down and drive away and say we're done. We've got to do something.
我们注意到了许多担忧，他把它们都写在他的本子里，然后我们离开了会议。我说，好吧，那么下一步是什么？他说，好吧，没什么。他说，我只是把这些记在我的本子里，如果以后再提起来，我可以说明我们是如何意识到这一点的。我当时想，好吧，这对我来说行不通。我说，这些人期望这里会有所作为。我们不能仅仅把它写下来，开车走人说我们完成了。我们必须做点什么。
Did you say that to him at the moment?
你当时对他说了吗？
I did.
我说了。
And what did he say back to you?
他回你什么？
He seemed shocked. He's like, well, that's just the way we've always done it.
他看起来很震惊。他好像是说，好吧，那只是我们一直以来的做法。
The cop Harpole is talking about, his whole job was to coordinate with residents. His title was Community Liaison Officer. Contrast that with what I saw at a daily briefing in district three. So much of it was cops discussing intel from residents and taking it seriously. They updated the captain about a meeting they'd held with people who lived near the site of a recent homicide who had helped them identify 17 nuisance properties where criminal activity might be going on. They read aloud from emails a guy sent them with the license plate of cars he saw picking up suspected prostitutes, and--
哈波尔提到的那个警察，他的全部工作就是与居民协调。他的头衔是“社区联络官”。对比我在第三区每日简报会上看到的。其中大部分是警察讨论居民提供的线索并认真对待。他们向队长更新了他们与最近发生凶杀案地点附近居民举行的会议情况，这些居民帮助他们确定了 17 处可能存在犯罪活动的干扰性房产。他们大声读出一个人发给他们的电子邮件，里面有他看到载有疑似妓女的汽车的车牌，并且——
One more update. If someone can help Dave from the bakery get in touch with Gorman Properties regarding some windows at 40th and Cherry.
还有一个更新。如果有人能帮面包店的戴夫联系到戈尔曼物业，关于 Cherry 大街 40 号的一些窗户的事。
They're broken?
它们坏了吗？
Yep.
是的。
OK.
好吧。
In case you didn't get that, this is literal broken window policing. They're going to get a landlord to replace some busted glass. Three years into Flynn's tenure, it was going pretty well. Violent crimes were down, homicides were down, citizen complaints against police were decreasing by quite a bit. Then in the summer of 2011, things took a bad turn, starting with the arrest of a man named Derek Williams. One night in July, officers responded to the scene of a robbery and found Williams. He was 22 years old, black. He ran. Officers chased him over a fence, caught him, handcuffed him, and put him in the back of a police car where a camera recorded what happened next.
如果你没听明白，这真的是 literal（字面意义上的）打破窗户的警务。他们要去请房东更换一些打碎的玻璃。弗林任期的第三年，一切进展顺利。暴力犯罪减少了，凶杀案减少了，针对警察的公民投诉也减少了不少。然后，2011 年夏天，事情发生了糟糕的转折，从一个名叫德里克·威廉姆斯的男子的被捕开始。七月的一天晚上，警察响应一起抢劫现场并发现了威廉姆斯。他 22 岁，黑人。他跑了。警察追他越过一道围栏，抓住了他，给他戴上手铐，并把他放在警车后座，车载摄像头记录了接下来的事情。
[INAUDIBLE].
（听不清）。
What's your last name?
你姓什么？
I can't breathe.
我喘不过气。
You're breathing just fine.
你呼吸得好好的。
Believe me.
相信我。
What's your last name?
你姓什么？
I can't breathe, Sir.
我喘不过气，长官。
You're just playing games.
你只是在演戏。
The video is horrible to watch. Minutes go by as Williams, shirtless and in handcuffs, writhes in the backseat, gasping for air. He pleads for medical attention but the officers ignore him.
视频非常可怕。几分钟过去了，威廉姆斯没穿衬衫戴着手铐，在后座扭动，大口喘气。他恳求医疗救助，但警官无视了他。
Help!
救命！
[GAGGING]
（干呕声）
This goes on for nearly eight minutes, then Derek Williams slumps over on the seat, at which point an officer opens the door and tries to wake him up.
这种情况持续了近八分钟，然后德里克·威廉姆斯瘫倒在座位上，这时一名警官打开车门试图叫醒他。
Hey, Derek. Derek.
嘿，德里克。德里克。
He checks his pulse. A few minutes later in the video, you see police administering CPR, but it was too late. Derek Williams died in the back of a squad car as he pleaded for medical help. It was Milwaukee's own Eric Garner video three years before it happened in New York. And through all the investigations, Chief Flynn defended the officers involved and they continued on active duty. People were furious. They protested, demanded that the state press criminal charges against the officers, demanded that the chief resign. Amazingly, Flynn says when he and other commanders first watched the video, they did not foresee that reaction.
他检查了他的脉搏。视频几分钟后，你看到警察在进行心肺复苏，但太晚了。德里克·威廉姆斯在警车后座恳求医疗帮助时死亡。这是密尔沃基在纽约那起事件发生三年前的埃里克·加纳视频。经过所有的调查，弗林局长为相关警官辩护，他们继续在职。人们愤怒了。他们抗议，要求州政府对这些警官提起刑事指控，要求局长辞职。令人惊讶的是，弗林说，当他和指挥官们第一次看视频时，他们并没有预见到那种反应。
Our first thought when that tape was finished was breathing a sigh of relief. Well gosh, the cops didn't do anything to him. And of course, what we're completely missing is that an average person seeing that tape is perceiving absolutely uncaring, unfeeling officers who refused to do anything about a man in distress, and we missed it.
我们第一次看完那盘磁带时的第一想法是松了一口气。哦，天哪，警察没对他做什么。当然，我们完全忽略的是，一个普通人看到那盘磁带会觉得这些警察完全冷漠、麻木，拒绝为陷入困境的人做任何事，而我们忽略了这一点。
Flynn says part of the disconnect stemmed from the fact that the video camera was infrared, so people watching it after the fact could see Derek Williams in a way the officers couldn't in the moment because it was dark. But the biggest problem, he says, is that he took for granted that the public would understand his reasoning for not disciplining the officers.
弗林说，部分断层源于视频摄像机是红外线的，所以事后观看的人可以以一种警察当时无法看到的方式看到德里克·威廉姆斯，因为当时天很黑。但他说，最大的问题是他理所当然地认为公众会理解他不惩戒这些警官的理由。
You know, in hindsight, one recognizes it's difficult to explain the universe of police officers in crisis situations and how often an average officer encounters an arrested suspect who doesn't want to go to jail and wants to go to the hospital.
你知道，事后看来，人们意识到解释警察在危机情况下的处境是很困难的，普通警察遇到一个不想入狱只想去医院的被捕嫌疑人的频率有多高。
That specific scenario happens a lot?
那种特定情况经常发生吗？
Exactly. I can't breathe, I have something wrong with me, I have a pain. And after a while, it becomes just part of the noise of making an arrest and officers get a little inured to it. Now, that's not something the public wants to hear the police chief try to explain when a young man just dropped dead in the back of a car, and so the lesson that was clear to us is if you say you can't breathe, OK, we're calling an ambulance.
完全正确。我不喘不过气，我有哪里不对劲，我疼。过了一段时间，它就成了逮捕过程的一部分噪音，警察也就对此有点麻木了。现在，这不是当一个年轻人刚刚在车后座死掉时，公众想听到警察局长试图解释的事情，所以对我们来说很清楚的教训是，如果你说你喘不过气，好吧，我们叫救护车。
You changed the policy?
你改变了政策？
We changed the policy. We made it mandatory. We probably tripled the number of ambulance runs for people under arrest going to jail, but we removed the officers' need to make a judgment.
我们改变了政策。我们使它成为强制性的。我们可能把逮捕送入监狱的人的救护车出勤次数增加了两倍，但我们消除了警察进行判断的需要。
I think part of what upset people so much about that, and what's upsetting to watch about it, I think it made people wonder why a policy is needed to have officers respond that way. You know, you look at this and it's kind of like, wouldn't it be basic human decency to respond to someone who's in distress like that or asking for help like that? And I wonder if you think that incident points to some kind of lack of empathy.
我想人们对那件事如此生气，以及观看那件事时感到不安的部分原因，是它让人们好奇为什么需要政策来让警察那样反应。你知道，你看着它，就像是，响应那些陷入困境或这样请求帮助的人，难道不是基本的社会公德吗？我想知道你是否认为那件事指向了某种缺乏同理心。
Cops start out empathetic or they wouldn't be doing this in the first place. You come to a police academy graduation, you talk to officers in training. They're dying to get out there and help people. But as the social net has frayed, cops are spending enormous amounts of time with the social problems that society's taken a walk on, and night after night after night, police officers go through the same problems for which there are no solutions.
警察最初是有同理心的，否则他们一开始就不会做这个。你来参加警察学院毕业典礼，和实习警察谈谈。他们渴望走出去帮助别人。但随着社会保障网的磨损，警察花费大量时间处理社会已经退出的社会问题，日复一日，夜晚复夜晚，警察经历着同样没有解决方案的问题。
The people that are police officers are regular people just like you, and they have faced the same kind of long term stresses on their equilibrium that anybody who is deployed year after year after year to Iraq and Afghanistan experiences. It happens more rapidly in a war zone, obviously, but the same dynamics are working on America's police officers every day on the streets of our cities, and they do harden themselves. They have to.
担任警察的人是和你们一样的普通人，他们面临着和任何年复一年被部署到伊拉克和阿富汗的人所经历的同样的长期压力。这显然在战区发生得更快，但同样的动力每天都在我们城市的街道上作用于美国的警察，他们确实使自己变得坚硬。他们必须这样做。
One thing Flynn says he's doing to try to rebuild empathy, he's trying to get cops on foot patrols at least an hour a shift so they can have friendly interactions with people who aren't in bad situations. Assistant Chief James Harpole says cynicism is especially dangerous to cops on third shift from midnight to 8:00 AM. He worked that shift for four years and he remembers the moment he realized he'd become jaded. It was when he got switched to second shift in the afternoons.
弗林说他正在做的一件事是试图重建同理心，他正在尝试让警察每班至少进行一小时的步行巡逻，这样他们就可以与那些不处于糟糕境地的人进行友好的互动。副局长詹姆斯·哈波尔说，愤世嫉俗对午夜到早上 8 点的三班倒警察尤其危险。他在那个班次工作了四年，他记得他意识到自己变得麻木的那一刻。那是当他被调到下午的二班倒时。
My first day working second shift was an eye opening experience for me. I'm driving down the street in the very same neighborhood I patrolled on third shift, and I see families, people pushing their babies, people waving at us as we were driving down the street. It shocked me. I was in shock. I had not experienced that. I realized at that very moment that the area that I was patrolling had an overwhelming majority of hardworking, outstanding individuals who wanted to have safe neighborhoods.
我工作二班倒的第一天对我来说是一次大开眼界的经历。我开车沿着我在三班倒巡逻的同一个街区，我看到家庭，人们推着他们的婴儿，人们在我们开车沿街行驶时向我们招手。它震惊了我。我很震惊。我没有经历过那个。我在那一刻意识到，我正在巡逻的地区有着绝大多数辛勤工作、杰出的个体，他们想要拥有安全的社区。
That hadn't occurred to you before, for real?
那之前没在你脑子里出现过，认真的吗？
Because I didn't deal with people like that. Before you even made it out of the station house, the dispatcher was sending you to the first fight and everybody was drunk and blood everywhere. So no, I hadn't even begun to think, is there anybody that's not like this?
因为我没处理过那样的人。在你离开警察局大楼之前，接线员就已经把你送到第一场打架现场，每个人都喝醉了，到处都是血。所以没有，我甚至没开始想，有谁不是这样的吗？
Harpole says working second shift completely changed his mindset for dealing with people on the job. I asked Chief Flynn if they ever change people's shifts with this in mind, rotate cops to give them different perspectives on a neighborhood, and he said they can't because the union contract doesn't allow them to. I told him it seemed like, from Harpole's story, there might be value in it. He said, yeah, there'd be value in renegotiating the contract, too.
哈波尔说，在二班倒工作彻底改变了他处理工作中心态的想法。我问弗林局长他们是否在考虑这一点的情况下换过人的班次，轮换警察给他们对街区的不同视角，他说他们不能，因为工会合同不允许他们这样做。我告诉他，从哈波尔的故事来看，似乎这样做可能有价值。他说，是的，重新谈判合同也有价值。
Brian Reed. Coming up, his story continues, and among other things, we go with Chief Flynn's officers as they try to solve a case, a shooting. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
布莱恩·里德。接下来，他的故事继续，除其他事项外，我们要跟随弗林局长的警察，当他们试图解决一个案件，一场枪击事件。那是来自芝加哥公共广播电台的节目，当我们的节目继续时，在一分钟内。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. This week and next on our show, "Cops See Things Differently," stories of policing and race. We're telling the story today of Chief Ed Flynn's tenure at the Milwaukee police department and how he's trying to improve relations between the police and black residents. One of the challenges he faced was he wanted to start a program that would basically be Milwaukee's version of the stop and frisk program, which is so controversial in New York City. Stop and frisk, of course, was policemen stopping pedestrians, but in Milwaukee, people drive, so lots of the stops were traffic stops. Again, here's Brian Reed.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。本周和下周在我们的节目中，“警察看待事物的方式”，关于警务和种族的报道。我们今天讲述的是埃德·弗林局长在密尔沃基警察局任期的故事，以及他如何试图改善警察与黑人居民之间的关系。他面临的挑战之一是他想发起一个基本上是密尔沃基版的“拦截盘查”（stop and frisk）项目，这在纽约市非常受争议。“拦截盘查”当然是警察拦截行人，但在密尔沃基，人们开车，所以很多拦截是交通拦截。再次，这是布莱恩·里德。
When Chief Flynn looked at the data from Milwaukee, he saw that when officers pulled over people in high crime areas more frequently for minor violations like having a taillight out or running a stop sign, car thefts went down. Flynn believed more stops would mean fewer crimes, so he wanted to do more stops, but somehow without angering people or alienating them.
当弗林局长查看密尔沃基的数据时，他看到，当警察更频繁地在高犯罪地区拦截那些因为小违规而违规的人，例如尾灯坏了或闯停牌，汽车盗窃案就会减少。弗林认为更多的拦截将意味着更少的犯罪，所以他想做更多的拦截，但不知何故不能激怒人们或疏远他们。
I also wanted to make sure we didn't accidentally enact a poor person's tax. If I'm going to put the cops on the hot spots and say enforce traffic laws because I really want to reduce robberies and car thefts, but I'm writing everybody tickets, how much good did I do myself? Maybe I'm going to reduce the number car thefts, but everybody hates us. So the order that implemented this policy said give warnings if you possibly can. The preferred outcome is a warning.
我还想确保我们没有意外地颁布穷人税。如果我要把警察放在热点地区并说执行交通法，因为我真的想减少抢劫和汽车盗窃，但我给每个人都开了罚单，我自己做了多少好事？也许我会减少汽车盗窃的数量，但每个人都恨我们。所以实施该政策的命令说，如果可能的话，给警告。优先结果是警告。
The number of traffic stops in Milwaukee almost quadrupled and the number of times officers stopped pedestrians tripled. And, like Flynn wanted, he says fewer than 20% of the traffic stops resulted in citation or arrest. Car thefts and robberies decreased, and Flynn saw an added benefit. Citizen complaints dropped, too. He thinks that's because more people were having good interactions with the cops, and there are numbers on this. A University of Wisconsin Milwaukee study that came out last month found that more than 60% of people who'd been approached by police during traffic stops said they were satisfied with how the officer handled the interaction.
密尔沃基的交通拦截次数增加了近四倍，警察拦截行人的次数增加了三倍。而且，正如弗林所愿，他说只有不到 20% 的交通拦截导致了传票或逮捕。汽车盗窃和抢劫减少了，弗林看到了额外的好处。公民投诉也减少了。他认为这是因为更多的人与警察有了良好的互动，而且这方面有数据。威斯康星大学密尔沃基分校上个月发布的一项研究发现，在交通拦截中被警察接近的人中，超过 60% 的人对警官处理互动的方式感到满意。
But it was also during these traffic stops and pedestrian stops that one of the biggest scandals of Flynn's tenure as police chief happened. Dozens of people are now suing the department. One of them is Brandon Graham. Brandon is 25 years old. He says he started getting stopped back sometime in 2011, about three years into Flynn's push to increase stops. The way Brandon remembers it, one day he went back to a neighborhood he used to live in on the north side of Milwaukee, and his friends kept telling him how the cops in that district, district five, had been harassing them constantly.
但也是在这些交通拦截和行人拦截期间，弗林担任警察局长任期内最大的丑闻之一发生了。现在有几十人正在起诉该部门。其中之一是布兰登·格雷厄姆。布兰登 25 岁。他说他大约在 2011 年开始被拦截，也就是在弗林推动增加拦截的大约三年后。布兰登记得那天的情况，一天他回到他过去住的密尔沃基北区的一个社区，他的朋友一直告诉他那个辖区——第五区——的警察是如何不断骚扰他们的。
I didn't really take it serious what they were saying. I'm thinking, like, you guys were doing something wrong to be stopped by the police. There's no police officer that's going to waste their time in Milwaukee, Wisconsin, where there's a lot of crime, to stop you from walking down the street.
我没太把他们说的话当回事。我在想，你们一定是做了什么错事才被警察拦截。没有哪个警察会浪费时间在威斯康星州密尔沃基，那里犯罪很多，去阻止你在街上走。
Brandon's naivete lasted for all of two hours. Sure enough, he says, that very afternoon, the cops came by.
布兰登的天真持续了整整两个小时。果然，他说，那天下午，警察来了。
We all stopped. I had no worries. I thought they were maybe looking for someone else, and I'm sure that it's not legal for the cops just to pull up and just pat you down with no probable cause. So we were all sitting there, and they asked me my name or whatever, asked me for my ID. I'm like, OK. I give them my ID or whatever. I'm like, is there any type of problems? They tell me to shut the F up.
我们都停下了。我没担心。我以为他们可能在找别人，而且我肯定警察只是开车过来并没有合理怀疑就搜身是不合法的。所以我们都坐在那儿，他们问我名字什么的，问我要身份证。我说，好吧。我给他们我的身份证什么的。我说，有什么问题吗？他们叫我闭上该死的嘴。
A warning. This gets explicit.
一个警告。这变得露骨了。
He grabbed my pants and pulled them up to almost where I was on my tiptoes, and once he did that, he rubbed his hand from the front all the way to the back, from my testicles to my buttocks back and forth. So I'm like, what's going on? I'm not understanding why this is happening. It seemed as though they were trying their best to intimidate us, how they were talking to everyone end and not waiting for an answer. And like I said, it's only the first time.
他抓着我的裤子向上拉，几乎拉到我脚尖着地，一旦他那样做了，他就从前到后，从我的睾丸到我的臀部来回摩擦我的手。所以我心想，发生了什么？我不明白为什么会这样。看起来他们正试图尽力恐吓我们，他们如何对每个人说话而不等回答。而且正如我所说，这只是第一次。
Soon after, Brandon ended up moving back to that neighborhood, and the random stops continued in the same style as that first one.
不久之后，布兰登最终搬回了那个社区，随机拦截也继续以第一次的那种风格进行。
So wait. How many times has this happened to you?
等等。这发生在你身上多少次了？
It's happened almost every single day, like a couple years, every day.
几乎每天都在发生，像几年，每一天。
One night, I spent time with Brandon and some of his friends back in district five. Brandon doesn't live there anymore, but they got to reminiscing about officers from the neighborhood, and listen to how well they knew them. It's like they're talking about old high school classmates or something.
一天晚上，我和布兰登以及他的一些朋友回到第五区。布兰登不再住在那儿了，但他们开始回忆起那个社区的警官，听听他们有多了解他们。就像他们在谈论高中老同学之类的。
You talking about the short, fat one?
你在说那个矮胖的吗？
No, the little short white dude. Slam. The one that slammed you all on the hood.
不，那个矮小的白人小子。Slam。那个把你们都撞到引擎盖上的那个。
You talking about Kapinsky?
你在说 Kapinsky 吗？
No. Kapinsky was kind of big.
不。Kapinsky 有点大块头。
Kapinsky's kind of big. I'm talking about the dude that's, like, your height.
Kapinsky 有点大块头。我在说那个，像你个子一样的那个家伙。
What time was it when it happened?
发生的时候是几点？
Late night.
深夜。
Oh. That's probably [INAUDIBLE] Letterman. Vag was probably in the green car that night. Because didn't Vag use to be in a white detail car?
哦。那可能是（听不清）Letterman。Vag 那晚可能在绿车里。因为 Vag 不是过去常在一辆白色的详细车里吗？
Yeah. That's the car he pulled in the driveway in, my aunt's driveway.
是的。那就是他开进车道的车，我姑姑的车道。
They're saying "Vag," short for Officer Michael Vagnini, the most notorious cop in the district at the time, and maybe all of Milwaukee. This is Brandon's friend P remembering the night officer Vagnini followed him into his aunt and uncle's driveway.
他们是在说“Vag”，Officer Michael Vagnini 的简称，当时那个辖区最臭名昭著的警察，也许整个密尔沃基都是。这是布兰登的朋友 P 回忆那个警察 Vagnini 跟踪他到他姑姑和叔叔车道的那晚。
[INAUDIBLE] walked all in her house. It's two something in the morning, walked all in the house, searched the house. Walked in my uncle's room. He's just getting out of the shower, butt ass naked. Oh yeah, man, put some clothes on. Fuck out of here, nigga. This ain't your motherfucking house. Get the fuck out. My uncle snapped, saying, do you got a search warrant? He said, let me put my clothes on. Let me call your sergeant and see if this is OK.
（听不清）一直走到她家里。那是凌晨两点多，一直走到房子里，搜查房子。走进我叔叔的房间。他刚洗完澡，赤身裸体。哦，是的，伙计，穿上点衣服。滚出去，黑鬼（Nigga）。这根本不是你妈的房子。滚出去。我叔叔爆发了，说，你有搜查证吗？他说，让我穿上衣服。让我打电话给你的中士，看看这是否可以。
It was this officer, Michael Vagnini, who Brandon says was responsible for the worst night of his life. He and some friends were in the car and a group of officers pulled them over. In court documents, the police say it was because they ran a stop sign and were missing a side mirror. They asked Brandon and his friends to get out of car. One officer patted Brandon down, then another. Again, Brandon's description is graphic.
就是这个警察，Michael Vagnini，布兰登说他对那晚最糟糕的生活负有责任。他和一些朋友在车里，一组警察拦下了他们。在法庭文件中，警方称这是因为他们闯了一个停牌并且少了一个侧镜。他们要求布兰登和他的朋友下车。一名警官给布兰登搜身，然后是另一名。布兰登的描述同样是图形化的。
Vagnini then was saying, I'm not a rookie, and then searched me. He stuck his hands in my boxers from the back first around my rectum area, and then reached around the front and kind of moved around my testicles. And the whole time, I'm having to hold my hands up, and every time I dropped my hands, he threatened me, you know, like if you drop your hands anymore, I'll kick you in the forehead. The whole time, I'm begging, please, Vag, you're touching my ass, you're touching my ass. You have your fingers around my butt hole. You're scratching me. You're lifting my testicles. It brought tears to my eyes because it's like, what can I do about this? When is it going to stop? The other officers are standing right there.
Vagnini 然后说，我不是菜鸟，然后搜查我。他先把手伸进我的平角裤里，在我的直肠区域，然后伸到前面，在我的睾丸周围移动。整个过程我不得不把手举起来，每次我放下手，他就威胁我，你知道，像如果你再放下手，我就踢你的额头。整个过程我一直在恳求，求求你，Vag，你在摸我的屁股，你在摸我的屁股。你的手指在我的肛门周围。你在抓我。你在提我的睾丸。这让我热泪盈眶，因为这就像，我能对此做什么？这什么时候能停止？其他警察就站在那儿。
Brandon says Officer Vagnini then pulled out a knife and cut open the waistband of his pants, where Brandon had two bags of cocaine. The officers arrested Brandon. He plead guilty to a misdemeanor possession charge. In the criminal complaint, the police say that Brandon consented to a search of his person. There's no description of the search.
布兰登说警察 Vagnini 然后掏出一把刀，割开了他裤子的腰带，布兰登在那里有两袋可卡因。警察逮捕了布兰登。他对一项轻罪持有指控认罪。在刑事诉状中，警方称布兰登同意对其人身进行搜查。没有关于搜查的描述。
Almost a year later, in 2012, Chief Flynn and the district attorney announced that they were investigating a pattern of complaints from the previous couple years about illegal searches, including illegal strip searches and cavity searches. Flynn asked any residents with information or complaints to call Internal Affairs. Three officers eventually plead no contest to being party to the illegal searches and were given community service. One went to jail for 20 days.
大约一年后，在 2012 年，弗林局长和地方检察官宣布他们正在调查过去几年关于非法搜查的一系列投诉，包括非法脱衣搜查和体腔搜查。弗林要求任何有信息或投诉的居民致电内部事务部。三名警官最终对作为非法搜查的一方提出不抗辩，并被判处社区服务。一人入狱 20 天。
Officer Vagnini plead no contest to four counts of illegal cavity searches and misconduct in public office. He was sentenced to a little more than two years in prison. For his sentencing, dozens of police officers wrote letters supporting him, saying his only crime was overzealousness in keeping the community safe from criminals. They called him exemplary, one of the best cops in the city, the kind of officer they wanted to be.
警官 Vagnini 对四项非法体腔搜查和公职人员渎职指控提出不抗辩。他被判入狱两年多。在他的判决中，几十名警察写信支持他，说他唯一的罪行是为保护社区免受犯罪分子伤害而过于热心。他们称他为模范，城市里最好的警察之一，他们想成为的那种警察。
But Vagnini's trial wasn't the end of it. About 60 people are now suing the department claiming they were also illegally searched. They name at least 40 officers and allege that supervisors looked the other way or ignored complaints.
但 Vagnini 的审判并不是结局。现在大约有 60 人在起诉该部门，声称他们也受到了非法搜查。他们点名了至少 40 名警官，并声称主管们转过头去或忽视了投诉。
A Milwaukee civil rights attorney who represented Frank Jude told me he'd been getting calls complaining about illegal searches for years before the chief announced his investigation. Even though he believed many of them and started to notice patterns involving specific officers, he couldn't prove the claims. Safran says a man who contacted him 10 years ago about an illegal search called him recently and said I told you so. Safran says some of the people who reported this behavior are still in prison because of the searches they say were illegal.
一名代理弗兰克·朱德的密尔沃基民权律师告诉我，他在局长宣布调查之前多年来一直收到关于非法搜查的投诉电话。尽管他相信其中许多并开始注意到涉及特定警官的模式，但他无法证明这些指控。Safran 说一个 10 年前联系过他关于非法搜查的人最近给他打电话说我告诉过你。Safran 说一些举报这种行为的人因为他们说非法的搜查仍然在监狱里。
It probably goes without saying that Brandon is one of the many black Milwaukeeans who has not been won over by Chief Flynn's campaign to build trust. I asked him and his friend Rex if they could picture a scenario in which they'd ever call the cops for help, if they got robbed at gunpoint, for instance.
可能不用说，布兰登是许多没有被弗林局长建立信任运动所赢得的黑人密尔沃基人之一。我问他和他的朋友 Rex，他们能否想象一个场景，他们会因为寻求帮助而打电话给警察，例如，如果他们被持枪抢劫。
You're asking if we're going to call the police?
你在问我们要不要打电话给警察吗？
Yes.
是的。
No. You would call the police, Rex?
不。你会打电话给警察，Rex？
Hell no. Hell motherfucking no.
去他的。去他妈的。
[INAUDIBLE] the police.
（听不清）警察。
Chief Flynn told me when he learned about the illegal searches and the cavity searches, he was furious and disappointed. He says this was a small, isolated group of officers who slipped into a game of getting the, quote, "bad guys" at all costs. But he also says he's skeptical of the people coming forward now claiming they were illegally searched and suing because of it. He called the lawsuits a cottage industry. He says the department only ever got three complaints and they were all from drug dealers who had been frequently arrested.
弗林局长告诉我，当他得知非法搜查和体腔搜查时，他感到愤怒和失望。他说这是一小群孤立的警察，他们陷入了一场不惜一切代价抓住“坏人”的游戏。但他还说，他现在对那些站出来声称他们受到非法搜查并因此起诉的人持怀疑态度。他称这些诉讼为“家庭手工业”。他说该部门总共只收到三个投诉，而且都是来自经常被捕的毒贩。
One thing that surprised me talking to Flynn, especially because he's such a student of history, was what he said when I asked him about the issue that's at the center of so many conversations about policing, race.
与弗林交谈令我惊讶的一件事，特别是因为他是这样一个历史学者，就是当我问他关于警务、种族这些对话核心的问题时他说的话。
At the level of cop working in the neighborhood, race is irrelevant. It's just people.
在社区工作的警察层面上，种族是不相关的。他们只是人。
Flynn says that whenever there's an incident between a white officer and a black resident, people get upset and say it's racism, but he says they're missing the big picture. So for instance, in 2011, The Milwaukee Journal Sentinel did a story where a data reporter looked at police records and found that black drivers in the city were seven times more likely than white drivers to be stopped by police. In response, Flynn did a whole presentation for residents with maps and crime numbers where he told them the same thing he told me, that the disparity isn't because of officers' bias against black residents. It's just that the majority of crimes happen in neighborhoods that are overwhelmingly African American.
弗林说，每当白人警察和黑人居民之间发生事件时，人们就会心烦意乱，说是种族主义，但他说他们忽略了大局。例如，2011 年，《密尔沃基哨兵报》做了一个报道，一名数据记者查看了警察记录，发现该市的黑人司机被警察拦截的可能性是白人司机的七倍。作为回应，弗林为居民做了一个全面的演讲，带有地图和犯罪数字，他告诉他们他在我这里说同样的事情，这种差异并不是因为警官对黑人居民的偏见。只是大多数犯罪发生在绝大多数是非裔美国人的街区。
And people come and say, we're shocked, shocked to find out the police are intervening so much in this neighborhood. What? What? Of course our interventions are going to generate disparities. I mean, they're going to match the disparities of where our crimes and victims are.
人们来并说，我们很震惊，震惊地发现警察在这个社区干预这么多。什么？什么？当然，我们的干预会产生差异。我的意思是，它们将匹配我们犯罪和受害者所在地的差异。
That may explain the statistics, but what I wanted to know was doesn't race play a role in those interventions? Only 17% of the Milwaukee police force is black in an incredibly segregated city. I told Flynn there's evidence that race can influence the way cops deal with black residents. Some of this we're going to talk about more in next week's show. There's research about people's implicit biases, subconscious racism that can affect officers' decisions.
这也许解释了统计数据，但我想知道的是，种族在那些干预中没有起到作用吗？在极其种族隔离的城市中，密尔沃基警察部队只有 17% 是黑人。我告诉弗林，有证据表明种族可以影响警察对待黑人居民的方式。其中一些我们将在下周的节目中讨论更多。有关于人们内隐偏见的研究，可能影响警官决定的潜意识种族主义。
But there's also evidence in Chief Flynn's own department, according to that Journal Sentinel story, which showed that the largest disparity between blacks and whites getting pulled over in Milwaukee didn't happen in high crime black areas of the city, but in the two lowest crime districts, both with predominantly white populations. The paper also found that once black drivers were pulled over, they were twice as likely as white drivers to have police search their cars, even though that didn't lead to finding more drugs or weapons. Flynn eventually said he's not trying to say race plays no role in policing.
但根据该哨兵报的报道，在弗林局长自己的部门也有证据，报道显示，黑人和白人在密尔沃基被拦截的最大差异并非发生在城市的高犯罪黑人区，而是在两个低犯罪辖区，都有主要是白人的人口。该论文还发现，一旦黑人司机被拦截，他们被警察搜查车辆的可能性是白人司机的两倍，尽管这并没导致找到更多的毒品或武器。弗林最终说他并不是试图说种族在警务中没有起到任何作用。
But what I am trying to say is that it does not play the role people think it does. The average reality of police working the same neighborhoods every day or every night, any biases you build up, tend to be based on a collection of experiences you've had based on the neighborhood in which you're working, and that counts for, in a practical way, more.
但我试图说的是，它并没有起到人们认为的那种作用。每天或每晚在同一个社区工作的警察的平均现实，你建立的任何偏见，往往是基于你根据你在工作的街区所拥有的经验集合，而从实际的角度来看，这更重要。
I left this conversation not feeling like the chief was denying a reality because it was uncomfortable for him to admit it, more like he honestly didn't see reality the way many other people do and the way I expected him to.
我离开这次谈话时并不觉得局长是在否认现实，因为承认它对他来说不舒服，更多地像是他诚实地没有像许多其他人那样看待现实，也没有像我期望他那样看待现实。
One interesting finding from that police satisfaction survey, while black people were much less likely to say they were satisfied with the police, if they'd called the police in the last year and it went well, that disparity almost completely disappeared. If the resident initiated the contact, not the police, one positive experience could make a difference.
那份警察满意度调查的一个有趣发现，虽然黑人对警察表示满意的可能性要小得多，如果他们在过去一年里报了警并且进展顺利，这种差异几乎完全消失了。如果居民发起的接触，不是警察，一次积极的经历就能有所作为。
Just want to pick it up a little bit here because the call was indicating that the female was shooting at her neighbor, so if that's the case, somebody was shot.
只是想在这里多提一点，因为电话显示女性正在向她的邻居开枪，所以如果是这种情况，有人被枪击了。
Someone on the phone line calling to say she was haggling with her neighbor about parking spots--
有人在电话线上打电话说她因为停车位正在与她的邻居讨价还价——
I'm in a squad car with Officer Richard Gordy speeding towards people who say their neighbor fired a gun at them. I'm going to tell you the story of the whole investigation of this potential shooting because first of all, it's just a good whodunit, and more important, it's black residents who called the police for help which, according to the survey at least, means if it goes well could totally change how the callers feel about the police.
我正和理查德·戈迪警官坐在警车里，急速赶往那些说邻居向他们开枪的人那里。我要告诉你整个调查这个潜在枪击事件的故事，因为首先，这只是一个很好的“谁干的”，更重要的是，是黑人居民要求警察帮助，这至少根据调查，意味着如果进展顺利，可以彻底改变报案人对警察的感觉。
OK. We're rolling up on the scene here, guys.
好的。我们正在到达现场，伙计们。
We arrive at a small apartment building. It's around 9:30 in the morning on a Tuesday. Officer Gordy drives by the small parking area in the back to see if there are any bullet casings. There aren't. He and another officer go inside the building and talk to people in there, but no one says they heard anything, and there's nothing coming up on Shot Spotter, so Officer Gordy sits in his squad car, contemplating his next move, until suddenly a green car pulls up right behind us and some people get out.
我们到达一栋小公寓楼。那是周二上午大约 9:30。戈迪警官开车经过后面的小停车区，看看是否有任何子弹弹壳。没有。他和另一名警官进去并在里面与人们交谈，但没人说他们听到了什么，而且在“枪声定位系统”上什么也没出现，所以戈迪警官坐在他的警车里，盘算着他的下一步行动，直到突然一辆绿车停在我们后面，一些人下了车。
[INAUDIBLE].
（听不清）。
Oh shit.
哦该死。
[INAUDIBLE].
（听不清）。
What's going on?
发生什么了？
It's a young couple.
是一对年轻夫妇。
Well, this morning, the lady downstairs, her car was parked behind our car, and we had to move the car so we could get out the driveway, but then she got hostile.
嗯，今天早上，楼下的女士，她的车停在我们的车后面，我们不得不移动车以便能开出车道，但然后她变得敌对了。
OK. You guys don't have a gun on you?
好吧。你们没带枪吗？
No. You can check my car, everything.
没有。你可以检查我的车，一切。
We ain't got no gun.
我们没有枪。
All right.
好吧。
She got hostile. She started cussing me out. She said, motherfucker, I ain't got to move my motherfucking car. So she got mad, and I said, listen, we're trying to get out the parking lot to drop the kids off. We had six kids with us. And she said, motherfucker, I ain't got to do shit, and she slammed the door. She came back out with a gun. And her--
她变得敌对了。她开始骂我。她说，该死的，我没必要移动我该死的车。所以她生气了，我说，听着，我们正在试图开出停车场送孩子们上学。我们有六个孩子和我们在一起。她说，该死的，我没必要做任何该死的事，她砰地关上了门。她带着枪又出来了。而她的——
This guy's name is Thomas. He's with his girlfriend, Trina. Thomas says after the neighbor came out with a gun, she then threatened to kill him, backed him down the hallway and out the back door, where Trina was waiting in the car with the kids.
这个人的名字是 Thomas。他和他的女朋友 Trina 在一起。Thomas 说，在邻居拿枪出来后，她威胁要杀了他，把他逼回走廊，逼出后门，Trina 正在车里带着孩子等着。
--I'm going to shoot you. So we're down there almost at the lot, and she shot at us by the car. She said, boom!
——我要杀了你。所以我们在那儿快到地段了，她在车旁向我们射击。她说，砰！
And the kids [INAUDIBLE].
孩子们（听不清）。
She said, boom.
她说，砰。
Where were you at when she shot at you?
她向你射击时你在哪儿？
We was in the car. I hopped in the car because she pointed at me again. I said--
我们在车里。我跳进车里，因为她又指着我。我说——
Where did she point at you with the gun?
她用枪指着你时在哪儿？
She pointed it at me. She's standing in the doorway like this. She pointed the gun at me like this.
她指着我。她站在门口像这样。她像这样用枪指着我。
Officer Gordy told me that they frequently get calls claiming there's a gun when there really isn't, just because people know the cops have to respond more quickly to that. Since there was no evidence of a shot fired, Gordy thought that might be what was going on here, so he separates Thomas from Trina and takes them alone into the police car.
戈迪警官告诉我，他们经常接到报案声称有枪，实际上根本没有，只是因为人们知道警察不得不更快地响应。因为没有开枪的证据，戈迪以为可能发生在这里，所以他把 Thomas 和 Trina 分开，独自带进警车。
You don't have a gun?
你没带枪？
No, I don't have a gun. I work at Walmart.
不，我没带枪。我在沃尔玛工作。
OK. Listen to me real quick here, OK, because there's a lot going on here. Very important that if she didn't shoot at you, just tell me she didn't shoot at you, but if she did, that's fine, too, but make sure you're telling the truth, the whole truth, and nothing but the truth.
好吧。快速听我说，好吗，因为这里有很多事情。非常重要，如果她没向你射击，直接告诉我她没向你射击，但如果她射了，那也很好，但确保你在说实话，全部事实，除了事实什么都没有。
I said she shot at me because--
我说她向我射击因为——
OK. That's OK. Listen to me real quick here. All I need to know is if she did or she didn't. If she didn't, that's fine. If it's a dispute, we'll handle that. But if she really did, make sure you're telling the truth, because if you're not, you'll be charged, OK? So did she or did she not? Because I'm getting ready to--
好吧。没关系。快速听我说。我只需要知道她是做了还是没做。如果她没做，那也很好。如果是纠纷，我们会处理。但如果她真的做了，确保你在说实话，因为如果你没做，你会被起诉，好吗？所以她是做了还是没做？因为我准备——
I can't say she-- if she shot directly at us, I'd have been hit, but she shot--
我不能说她——如果她直接向我们射击，我就会被击中了，但她射了——
Was a gun shot? Was a gun fired?
是枪响了吗？是枪开火了吗？
The gun was fired.
枪开火了。
Look at this. Can I show you something here? You know what Shot Spotter is? This detects gunshots. I've got no gunshots here. That's why I'm asking you. This is technology. This is satellite technology. Shots fired. There's nothing here. That's why I'm asking you.
看看这个。我能给你看点东西吗？你知道什么是“枪声定位系统”吗？这检测枪声。我这里没有枪声。这就是为什么我问你。这是技术。这是卫星技术。开枪了。这里什么都没有。这就是为什么我问你。
The thing Gordy is not telling Thomas is that he doesn't think Shot Spotter covers the block we're on, but he doesn't tell him that because even though Thomas is the one who wanted the cops' help and says he was the victim, Gordy is trying to figure out if he's lying. He's approaching Thomas as a potential victim and a potential suspect, and it gets to Thomas. He starts to backtrack a bit with his story.
戈迪没告诉 Thomas 的是，他认为“枪声定位系统”不覆盖我们在的街区，但他没告诉他，因为尽管 Thomas 是那个想要警察帮助并说他是受害者的人，戈迪正在试图找出他是否在撒谎。他正在接近 Thomas 作为潜在的受害者和潜在的嫌疑人，这触动了 Thomas。他开始稍微退缩他的故事。
I don't know if there were bullets in the gun. She pulled it and pop.
我不知道枪里是否有子弹。她掏出来，砰。
Did you hear a gunshot?
你听到枪声了吗？
Yes. Yes. I heard a gunshot. I was right there. She pointed the gun at me. She said, look, I'm going to kill you.
是的。是的。我听到一声枪响。我就在那儿。她用枪指着我。她说，听着，我要杀了你。
Meanwhile, inside the building, other officers have found the alleged shooter, a woman named Charday. They didn't find Charday in her own apartment-- she was in one down the hall-- and she has quite a different story to tell about Thomas.
同时，在楼里，其他警察找到了被指控的枪手，一个名叫 Charday 的女人。他们没在她的公寓里找到 Charday——她在走廊下面的另一间——她对 Thomas 有截然不同的故事。
Then he starts kicking my door, he starts kicking in my door and shaking my doorknob.
然后他开始踢我的门，他开始踢门并摇我的门把手。
Why is he down here banging on your door?
他为什么要在你门外敲门？
Because he wanted me to move my car.
因为他想让我移动我的车。
OK.
好吧。
And I told him I was getting to put my clothes on and move my car, and he said, this bitch is not moving her car, so he got to kick in my door. [INAUDIBLE] arguing with my kids, calling them all kinds of ho's and bitches and he will whoop their ass, so I was scared for my kids to go outside because no telling if a person can harm my child.
我告诉他我正准备穿上衣服移动我的车，他说，这个婊子不移动她的车，所以他必须踢我的门。（听不清）和我的孩子们争吵，叫他们所有种类的妓女和婊子，他会打他们的屁股，所以我很害怕我的孩子出门，因为不知道一个人是否能伤害我的孩子。
OK. There is alleged that a shot was fired today here.
好吧。今天这里有人指控开了一枪。
I didn't hear no shots.
我没听到任何枪声。
Did anyone have a gun?
有人有枪吗？
No. No one had a gun. I don't even think they had a gun.
没有。没有人有枪。我甚至不认为他们有枪。
Is there a weapon in here?
这里有武器吗？
No.
没有。
Do you own a weapon?
你拥有武器吗？
No, I do not. I had my house searched before. You could search my house.
不，我不拥有。我的房子之前被搜查过。你可以搜查我的房子。
It's not about that, OK? It's about getting to the bottom of this. I don't want to have to go, get search warrant, tear your house upside down here looking for a pistol.
这不是关于那个，好吗？这是关于弄清楚这件事的底细。我不想必须去，拿到搜查证，把你的房子倒过来搜查这里找一把手枪。
You can search it now.
你可以现在就搜查。
For obvious reasons, officers are focusing on whether or not there was a gun involved in whatever happened during this dispute. Outside, the cops ask Thomas over and over, all different ways, if there had been a gun, if he'd seen a gun, if a gun had been fired. They do the same thing with Thomas's girlfriend, Trina. Again, these are the people who asked for the cops to help them. Officer Gordy takes Trina out back to the parking lot and has her act out how it went down.
出于显而易见的原因，警察正专注于无论这起纠纷期间发生了什么，是否涉及枪支。在外面，警察一遍又一遍地问 Thomas，各种方式，如果有一把枪，如果他看到了一把枪，如果一把枪被发射了。他们对 Thomas 的女朋友 Trina 也做了同样的事情。再次，这些是要求警察帮助的人。戈迪警官带 Trina 出去后面到停车场，让她演示发生了什么。
--like that, so she was like, bah!
——那样，所以她就像，吧！
Show me exactly where you were when you saw her fire.
准确地告诉我你在看到她开火时在哪儿。
I see smoke come out the gun. I didn't see where the--
我看到烟从枪里出来。我没看到——
Did you ever hear her? Did you ever hear the gunshot fired?
你听到她开火的枪声了吗？
Yeah. It was like, bah!
是的。它是像，吧！
Did you ever see a flash come out of the gun?
你看到闪光从枪里出来了吗？
I've seen white smoke, like puh.
我看到了白烟，像噗。
So that would be the direction that it went?
所以那会是它去的方向？
Yeah, right here. My boyfriend was standing right there.
是的，就在这里。我男朋友当时站在那儿。
Don't you think if she fired, that something here would have been hit?
你不觉得如果她开火了，这里的什么东西会被击中吗？
I don't know. I ain't never seen no gun, so I don't know.
我不知道。我从来没见过枪，所以我不知道。
At this point, everyone's pissed. Trina is outside complaining to Thomas about how you can't even get help from the police, how they only care if someone's dead. And inside, Charday is sitting handcuffed. She's not arrested, but in handcuffs, as officers tear up her apartment looking for a gun.
在这一点上，每个人都气疯了。Trina 在外面向 Thomas 抱怨你怎么甚至不能从警察那里得到帮助，他们只关心是否有人死了。而在里面，Charday 正坐着戴着手铐。她没被捕，但戴着手铐，当警察搜查她的公寓找枪时。
Look at y'all. I've got a brand new blanket on the floor. Y'all got shit all over the floor. Come on, now. Y'all are doing it reckless. Shit. Now I'm already letting y'all in my house searching. If I did have something, I wouldn't be hiding it in my damn kids' clothes.
看看你们。我的地板上有一条崭新的毯子。你们在地板上弄了一堆东西。来吧，现在。你们做得很鲁莽。该死。我已经让你们进我的房子搜查。如果我确实有什么东西，我不会把它藏在我该死的孩子的衣服里。
I'd like to believe you, but after 22 years, you'd be shocked what I've found and where I've found it.
我希望能相信你，但在 22 年后，你会震惊我找到了什么以及我在哪里找到它。
As for the cops, they're having trouble figuring out the truth. I heard the supervising officer on the scene, a sergeant, whisper to officer Gordy that he thought they should arrest both Charday and Thomas for fighting. Almost an hour passed. Inside, the officers continued to look through Charday's things, and then-- I'm not even sure if any of the cops noticed this-- a few tears began to run down Charday's face. Not long after, in a hamper full of dirty clothes in the closet, they found a gun, a long black revolver, exactly what both Thomas and Trina had independently described. It had one spent bullet.
至于警察，他们在弄清楚真相方面遇到了麻烦。我听到现场的督导警官，一名中士，低声对戈迪警官说，他认为他们应该因为打架逮捕 Charday 和 Thomas。差不多过了一个小时。在里面，警察继续查看 Charday 的东西，然后——我甚至不确定是否有警察注意到这一点——几滴泪水开始顺着 Charday 的脸流下。没过多久，在壁橱里的一筐脏衣服里，他们发现了一把枪，一把长黑左轮手枪，正是 Thomas 和 Trina 独立描述的东西。它有一颗耗尽的子弹。
The cops arrested Charday for recklessly endangering safety by use of a firearm. Officer Gordy let her change out of her pajamas into warmer clothes, made sure her grandma was able to watch her kids, and then walked her out of the building in handcuffs.
警察因使用枪支鲁莽危及安全逮捕了 Charday。戈迪警官让她从睡衣换成更暖和的衣服，确保她奶奶能看住她的孩子，然后把她戴着手铐走出大楼。
The kids are all taken care of and everything? It's OK that they're going to be with Grandma?
孩子们都照顾好了，一切都好了吗？他们和奶奶在一起没问题吧？
Yeah.
是的。
Are you crying?
你在哭吗？
As all this was wrapping up, Trina called me over. She said she had something to say about the police.
当所有这一切都结束时，Trina 叫我过去。她说她有关于警察的话要说。
You see how they do us? They don't believe us. Somebody could have been dead. You feel me? They was trying to say we were a liar, I mean, not [INAUDIBLE] was a liar, but they were trying to make it seem like it wasn't nothing when it was something. She shot at me and my boyfriend and five kids in the car.
你看到他们如何对待我们了吗？他们不相信我们。有人本可能死掉。你感觉到吗？他们试图说我们是骗子，我的意思是，不（听不清）是骗子，但他们试图让它看起来好像没什么事，当它有事时。她向我和我男朋友以及车里的五个孩子开枪。
Trina pointed to a group of guys who had been hanging around the block while the investigation was going on. She told me they were Charday's people, cousins, and that Charday had threatened that they would go after Trina and her boyfriend.
Trina 指着一群在调查进行时在街区徘徊的家伙。她告诉我他们是 Charday 的人，表兄弟，而且 Charday 威胁说他们会去找 Trina 和她男朋友。
That's how people end up dead. When you call the police, you're being a snitch for real. Police got to take cautions right then and there. If they don't, when they leave, people get killed like that. You know what I'm saying? That's what I'm telling the police.
人们就是这样死掉的。当你打电话给警察时，你真的是在当告密者。警察必须当时就采取预防措施。如果他们不这样做，当他们离开时，人们就像那样被杀掉。你知道我正在说什么吗？这就是我正在告诉警察的。
So you were worried that the police weren't going to believe you, they weren't going to find a gun.
所以你担心警察不会相信你，他们不会找到枪。
And they were going to leave and I was going to be here by myself and they were going to start some other stuff up.
而且他们会离开，我将独自留在这里，他们会开始其他事情。
I mean, it seemed like it worked out, though.
我的意思是，它看起来确实成功了，不过。
Yeah, it did, but they just really weren't believing us today, [INAUDIBLE] the gun, but that's just history, anyway. These white thugs, they judge you on how you look.
是的，它确实，但他们今天真的不相信我们，（听不清）枪，但这只是历史，无论如何。这些白人暴徒，他们根据你的外表来评判你。
Cops need to be skeptical during investigations. It's built into their jobs. They aren't supposed to fully trust the person they're talking to. But of course, the person they're talking to can feel that. Trina and Thomas did. And it's upsetting if you've just been shot at to have the police come and interrogate you like you're the criminal. And on top of that, there's the history, all the times the cops haven't treated people fairly or worse. That's always there, casting a shadow over every interaction. The cops feel like they're just doing their job the way they always do, but for Trina, it's hard not to wonder if the cops would be treating her this way if she was white.
警察需要在调查期间持怀疑态度。这是他们工作的一部分。他们不应该完全相信他们正在交谈的人。但当然，他们正在交谈的人可以感觉到。Trina 和 Thomas 感到了。如果你刚刚被射击而有警察来并且像你是罪犯一样审问你，那是令人沮丧的。而且最重要的是，有历史，所有警察没有公平对待人们或者更糟的时候。那总是存在的，在每一次互动上投下阴影。警察觉得他们只是在做他们一直做的工作，但对于 Trina 来说，如果她是白人，很难不怀疑警察是否会这样对待她。
One last story. On April 30 last year, a white Milwaukee police officer shot and killed a black man named Dontre Hamilton. He was sleeping in a plaza across from City Hall in the afternoon, and an employee from a nearby Starbucks called the police. Two officers checked on Hamilton and determined he wasn't doing anything wrong. Then a different cop, the beat cop for the area, Officer Christopher Manny, came and roused him and tried to pat him down. This led to some kind of altercation. According to officer Manny and some witnesses, Hamilton grabbed his baton and hit him in the neck with it. Manny says he feared for his life. He shot Hamilton 14 times. Hamilton was 31 years old and had suffered from schizophrenia.
最后一个故事。去年 4 月 30 日，一名白人密尔沃基警官枪杀了一名黑人男子，名叫 Dontre Hamilton。他下午睡在市政厅对面的广场上，附近一家星巴克的员工报了警。两名警官检查了 Hamilton 并确定他没做错任何事。然后另一个警察，该地区的巡警，Christopher Manny 警官，来叫醒他并试图搜身。这导致了某种争执。根据 Manny 警官和一些证人，Hamilton 抓住了他的警棍并用它击中了他的脖子。Manny 说他担心自己的生命。他射击 Hamilton 14 次。Hamilton 31 岁，患有精神分裂症。
And unlike after the death of Derek Williams, the man in the back of a squad car who couldn't breathe, Chief Flynn fired officer Manny, though he didn't fire him for killing Hamilton. He fired him for doing a pat down that was against department policy and not in line with his training. Flynn says Officer Manny could tell when he approached that Hamilton was in the midst of a mental health issue, which means he should have never tried to touch him. That's rule number one when dealing with someone in a mental health crisis. And by trying to pat him down, Flynn says, Manny created the situation in which he feared for his life and ended up killing Dontre Hamilton.
而且与在警车后座喘不过气的德里克·威廉姆斯死后不同，弗林局长解雇了 Manny 警官，尽管他并不是因为杀死了 Hamilton 而解雇他。他解雇他是因为他进行了违背部门政策且不符合他训练的搜身。弗林说 Manny 警官在他靠近时可以看出 Hamilton 正处于心理健康问题中，这意味着他根本不应该试图触摸他。在处理处于心理健康危机的人时，那是第一条规则。通过试图搜身，弗林说，Manny 创造了他担心自己生命并最终杀死了 Dontre Hamilton 的局面。
It was [INAUDIBLE].
那是（听不清）。
It was murder. It was murder!
那是谋杀。那是谋杀！
In November, after Officer Manny appealed Chief Flynn's decision to fire him, the public was given a chance to comment before Milwaukee's fire and police commission. I was there. People packed into a senior center gymnasium. On the right, members of the police union, almost entirely white. On the left, Dontre Hamilton's family and supporters, largely black and brown.
11 月，在 Manny 警官上诉弗林局长解雇他的决定后，公众有机会在密尔沃基消防和警察委员会之前发表评论。我在那儿。人们挤进了一个老年中心体育馆。右边，工会成员，几乎全是白人。左边，Dontre Hamilton 的家人和支持者，主要是黑人和棕色人。
For an hour, Chief Flynn and the commission sat silently on stage as supporters of Dontre Hamilton berated them. They were angry that Flynn had taken six months to make a decision about Manny's firing, that he'd announced it two days after Manny had filed for disability, which meant he could still get paid, and that under a new state law, what was supposed to be an independent investigation into Dontre Hamilton's death had been done by former Milwaukee police officers. On the other side, the police union members were furious that Flynn would even consider suspending Officer Manny, never mind firing him, for doing what union president Mike Crivello said any reasonable officer would do in that situation.
有一个小时，弗林局长和委员会默默地坐在台上，当 Dontre Hamilton 的支持者责骂他们时。他们很愤怒，因为弗林花了六个月时间才做出关于 Manny 解雇的决定，他在 Manny 申请残疾两天后宣布了它，这意味着他仍然可以拿到报酬，并且根据一项新的州法律，本来应该是对 Dontre Hamilton 死亡的独立调查是由前密尔沃基警察做的。另一方面，工会成员很愤怒，弗林竟然考虑停职 Manny 警官，更不用说解雇他了，因为做工会主席 Mike Crivello 所说的任何理性的警察在那种情况下都会做的事。
When the situation created the necessity for the use of a deadly force, PO Manny did what he had to. Certainly would have rather not have had to. Certainly would have rather not have had to. We are grateful he survived. I am 100% confident that a [INAUDIBLE] tragedy. We are saddened by the loss of Mr. Hamilton. We have compassion for the family. I am praying for peace for the Hamilton family.
当情况创造了使用致命武力的必要性时，PO Manny 做了他必须做的事。当然本来更愿意没必须那样做。当然本来更愿意没必须那样做。我们很感激他幸存下来。我 100% 确信那是（听不清）悲剧。我们对 Hamilton 先生的损失感到悲伤。我们对家人有同情心。我正在为 Hamilton 家人的和平祈祷。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
（交叉发言）
There was one thing both sides could agree on. They both wanted Chief Flynn gone. Dontre Hamilton's supporters had issued a demand for his resignation, and the union had recently held a no confidence vote, where 99% of the cops who showed up had voted against the chief. At one point during the public comments, Chief Flynn began to look down at his lap. He was checking this phone. People shouted at him, saying how dare he, saying he was being insensitive. After the meeting, in the lobby of the senior center as Flynn was on his way out, he addressed it with a scrum of reporters.
有一件事双方可以达成一致。他们都想要弗林局长离开。Dontre Hamilton 的支持者发出了辞职要求，工会最近举行了不信任投票，99% 到场的警察投票反对局长。在公众评论期间，弗林局长开始看着他的膝盖。他正在查看这个电话。人们对他大喊大叫，说他怎么敢，说他不够敏感。会议结束后，在大厅里，当弗林离开时，他用一群记者解决了它。
Well, I was on my phone, and yes, that's true. I was following developments with a five-year-old little girl sitting on her dad's lap who had just got shot in the head by a drive by shooting. And if some of the people here gave a good goddamn about the victimization of people in this community by crime, I'd take some of their invective more seriously.
嗯，我在用我的手机，是的，那是真的。我正在追踪一个坐在她爸爸膝盖上的五岁小女孩的进展，她刚被枪击中头部，是驾车枪击。如果这里有些人对这个社区的人们因犯罪而受害给予很好的上帝的诅咒，我会更认真地对待他们的一些辱骂。
The greatest racial disparity in the city of Milwaukee is getting shot and killed. Hello. 80% of my homicide victims every year are African American. 80% of our aggravated assault victims are African American. 80% of our shooting victims who survive their shooting are African American. Now, they know all about the last three people that have been killed by the Milwaukee police department over the course of the last several years. There's not one of them can name one of the last three homicide victims we've had in this city.
密尔沃基市最大的种族差异是被枪击并杀害。你好。每年 80% 的凶杀案受害者是非裔美国人。80% 的严重袭击受害者是非裔美国人。80% 幸存枪击的枪击受害者是非裔美国人。现在，他们知道过去几年密尔沃基警察部门杀害的最后三个人的一切。他们中没有一个人能说出我们在该市最近的三名凶杀案受害者中任何一个人的名字。
Now, there's room for everybody to participate in fixing this police department, and I'm not pretending we're without sin, but this community is at risk, all right, and it's not because men and women in blue risk their lives protecting it. It's at risk because we've got large numbers of high capacity quality firearms in the hands of remorseless criminals who don't care who they shoot. Now, I'm leaving here to go to that scene.
现在，每个人都有参与修复这个警察部门的空间，我不是假装我们没有罪，但这个社区处于危险之中，好吧，它并不是因为蓝色的男人和女人冒着生命危险保护它。它处于危险之中，因为我们有大量高容量高质量的枪支在那些不关心他们射击谁的冷酷犯罪分子手中。现在，我要离开这里去那个现场。
And I take it personally, OK? We're going up there and there's a bunch of cops processing a scene of a dead kid. They're the ones that are going to take the risks to their life to try to clean this thing up, all right? We are responsible for the things we get wrong and we take action. We've arrested cops, we've fired cops, and so on. But when you start getting yelled at for reading the updates of the kid that got shot, yeah, you take it personal, OK? Now no offense, but I'm going up there now.
而且我个人承担，好吗？我们正在去那儿，有一堆警察正在处理一个死小孩的现场。他们是那些将冒着生命危险试图清理这个东西的人，好吗？我们对我们做错的事情负责，并且我们采取行动。我们逮捕了警察，我们解雇了警察，等等。但当你开始因为阅读刚被枪击的孩子的更新而遭到责骂时，是的，你把它个人化，好吗？现在没冒犯，但我现在要去那儿了。
If you're going to repair the relationship between African Americans and the police, at least the way Chief Flynn is trying to, it's going to happen in the course of thousands of encounters between cops and black residents, thousands of encounters that need to go well, and even if they do, each one still only brings you one small step closer to building trust. It's a game of inches.
如果你要修复非裔美国人与警察之间的关系，至少是弗林局长试图这样做的方式，它将在警察与黑人居民之间数千次接触的过程中发生，数千次需要进展顺利的接触，即使它们确实做到了，每一个仍然只带你向建立信任更近一小步。这是一场英寸的游戏。
Right now, according to that University of Wisconsin survey, 63% of black Milwaukeeans say they're satisfied with police, versus 83% of white Milwaukeeans. Remember Trina, the woman whose neighbor shot at her and her boyfriend? On paper, her case looks like a success for the Milwaukee police. They arrested the shooter, confiscated the gun, and on top of that, they helped Trina out, offered to stand guard while Trina and her boyfriend moved out of the apartment building that day to make sure the neighbor's cousins didn't do anything to them. Trina thanked the officers before they left, and still, when we talked about if she trusted the Milwaukee PD, she said--
现在，根据威斯康星大学的那项调查，63% 的黑人密尔沃基人说他们对警察满意，对比 83% 的白人密尔沃基人。还记得 Trina 吗，那个邻居向她和她男朋友开枪的女士？在纸面上，她的案例看起来是密尔沃基警察的成功。他们逮捕了枪手，没收了枪支，最重要的是，他们帮了 Trina，提议当 Trina 和她男朋友那天搬离公寓楼时站在岗哨，确保邻居的表兄弟不会对他们做什么。Trina 在他们离开前感谢了警官，仍然，当我们谈论她是否信任密尔沃基警察时，她说——
I don't really. It's a 50/50 chance, you know what I'm saying? 50/50.
我真的不信任。这是 50/50 的机会，你知道我正在说什么吗？50/50。
50/50 chance of what?
50/50 什么的机会？
Like sometimes they help people, sometimes they wouldn't. You know what I'm saying? That was the grace of god that they found that gun.
就像有时他们帮助人们，有时他们不会。你知道我正在说什么吗？那是上帝的恩典，他们找到了那把枪。
Sometimes they'll help you and sometimes they won't?
有时他们会帮助你，有时他们不会？
Yeah. They won't.
是的。他们不会。
Trina is not the only black Milwaukeean who said something like this to me. I asked one woman what she thought of the Milwaukee PD and she put it like this. You just don't know what to expect. That stayed with me. She wasn't saying all cops are racist or the whole force is corrupt. She was saying something much more measured, that the police are unpredictable, which means at least this woman felt that when you have an interaction with a cop, you can never be sure what you're going to get.
Trina 不是唯一一个对我这样说的黑人密尔沃基人。我问一个女人她对密尔沃基警察有什么看法，她这样表达。你只是不知道会发生什么。那留在了我的脑子里。她并不是在说所有的警察都是种族主义者或者整个部队都是腐败的。她说了一些衡量得多的事情，警察是不可预测的，这意味着至少这个女人感到当你与警察进行互动时，你永远无法确定你会得到什么。
Brian Reed is one of the producers of our program. Ben Calhoun helped produce that story. Next week, some cities where policing is so different from Milwaukee in the second week of our series.
布莱恩·里德是我们节目的制片人之一。本·卡尔霍恩帮忙制作了这个故事。下周，一些城市的警务与密尔沃基在我们的系列节目的第二周非常不同。
Our program was produced today by Brian Reed with Sean Cole, Stephanie [INAUDIBLE], Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Editing by Joel Lovell. Production help from Simon Adler. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our office manager. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Elna Baker scout stories for our show. Research help from Michelle Harris, Christopher Swetala, and Ben Anastas. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
我们的节目今天由布莱恩·里德与肖恩·科尔、斯蒂芬妮（听不清）、Chana Joffe-Walt、米奇·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克制作。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。由乔尔·洛弗尔编辑。西蒙·阿德勒的制作帮助。塞思·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。艾丽丝·伯格森是我们的办公室经理。阿德里安·马蒂奥维茨经营我们的网站。埃尔娜·贝克为我们的节目探查故事。米歇尔·哈里斯、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉和本·阿纳斯塔斯的调查帮助。来自达米安·格拉夫和罗布·格迪斯的音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX. the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he finally met a few of our listeners at a WBEZ event, and I don't know what he was thinking. They were very different from what he expected.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由 PRX——公共广播交流平台交付给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他终于在一次 WBEZ 活动中见到我们的一些听众，我不知道他在想什么。他们和他预期的非常不同。
I see families, people pushing their babies. It shocked me. I was in shock.
我看到家庭，人们推着他们的婴儿。它震惊了我。我很震惊。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with part two of our series on policing and more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着我们关于警务的系列节目的第二部分和更多《美国生活》的故事回来。